what's up everybody I'm so excited
because today we are going to unbox this
entire Disney bitty Bop collection from
Funko just look how cute and tiny sauce
from Mickey is what you get in this box
are 36 Beauty Box with 12 different
designs of your favorite Disney
characters so let it rip what we have
here are two variations of Mickey Mouse
four variations of Minnie Mouse
Daisy Duck
Donald Duck
Goofy
Chippendales
and of course Pluto they're so adorable
and we're so in love with them just look
at how cute they look when they're
stacked neatly if you're an avid Funko
collector this is something you might
want to expand your collection with it's
a sure win of three sets so there's
plenty to go around for your friends and
family